aquí
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre de
liliana valencia aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
en el norte de mozambique miles de
personas huyeron de la ciudad de palma
después de que grupos yihadistas tomaran
el control y dejarán también decenas de
muertos
la empresa que adelantaba a proyectos de
explotación de gas en la región
suspendió sus operaciones al igual que
el programa mundial de alimentos
el aporte para el internacional ratificó
la absolución por falta de pruebas del
ex presidente de costa de marfil laurent
gbagbo el ex mandatario había sido
acusado de crímenes de lesa humanidad
durante el conflicto poselectoral de
2010 que dejó también decenas y
centenares de muertos
el gobierno interino del ciudadano firmó
un acuerdo con el denominado movimiento
de liberación popular de sudán del norte
con el objetivo de garantizar la
libertad de justicia para las religiones
del estado se espera que este pacto
constituya un paso más hacia el camino
de la paz y la democracia
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
mozambique porque los sobrevivientes de
un ataque en la ciudad de palmas
entraron al puerto de pemba ya son más
de 8000 las personas que han sido
desplazadas tras el ataque yihadista
registrado en ese territorio del norte
del país la unión africana de naciones
pidió una acción internacional
coordinada para afrontar lo que llamó
una urgente amenaza para la paz y la
seguridad regional mientras que el
programa mundial de alimentos suspendió
sus operaciones en la zona al igual que
la empresa francesa que adelantaba
grandes proyectos de explotación de gas
veamos
con ansiedad estas personas esperan a
las afueras del puerto de pemba mientras
tratan de ubicar a sus familiares que
lograron llegar a un lugar seguro
decenas de sobrevivientes llegaron en
barcos este jueves luego del ataque
ocurrido la semana pasada en la ciudad
de palmas a 200 kilómetros de allí un
gran alivio para algunos mientras que
otros temen por aquellos de los que no
se tiene noticia estoy muy cansada más
de siete días en los arbustos estoy
exhausta nos cruzamos varias veces con
los atacantes la situación es realmente
difícil muchas personas murieron as
más de 8000 personas la mitad de ellas
niños han sido forzadas a desplazarse de
acuerdo con naciones unidas y muchas más
viven bajo difíciles condiciones
mientras esperan su turno para ser
evacuadas aún hay muchas personas
alrededor de 5000 esperando para ser
evacuadas a pemba
y se están quedando sin comida y sin
agua
la evacuación fue impulsada por un
ataque de yihadistas ocurrido en la
ciudad de palm hace una semana docenas
de personas fueron asesinadas mientras
que cientos de militantes vinculados con
el estado islámico atacaron tiendas
bancos e instalaciones militares los
soldados se encuentran en la zona
tratando de asegurar la ciudad entonces
aún no hemos asegurado toda la ciudad
estamos patrullando y consolidando las
áreas principales mientras desplazamos a
nuestros soldados para proteger el
perímetro el ataque es la mayor escalada
de la insurgencia islamista que inició
en el norte de mozambique en 2017 y
hasta el momento deja más de 2500
asesinados y alrededor de 700.000
desplazados
la corte penal internacional de atípico
la absolución por falta de pruebas del
ex presidente de costa marfil laurent
gbagbo había sido acusado de crímenes
contra la humanidad durante la violencia
postelectoral de 2010 en su país tan
negarse a aceptar la derrota ante la
actual presidente alassane ouattara los
cargos los llevaron a pasar siete años
tras las rejas y su juicio fue el
primero de un jefe de estado dictaminado
por la corte penal internacional veamos
en abiyán los simpatizantes del ex
presidente de costa de marfil laurent
gbagbo celebran la confirmación de la
absolución de los cargos de crímenes
contra la humanidad por la corte penal
internacional la decisión puede abrir el
camino para que el back book que ha
estado viviendo en bélgica regrese al
país africano
ahora estamos esperando al expresidente
en la villa no será honrado espero que
el gobierno haga un esfuerzo para que el
ex presidente back lo pueda volver que
todos los exiliados puedan volver sin
caos sin problemas para que se realice
la tan necesaria reconciliación en este
país el caso de bach wood tuvo su origen
en 2010 cuando el que había sido
presidente desde el año 2000 se negó a
reconocer la derrota electoral ante el
actual mandatario alassane ouattara la
el país estalló en una guerra civil que
mató a 3.000 personas bambú fue absuelto
en primera instancia en enero de 2019
y extender coles una sala de apelación
decidió por mayoría rechazar el recurso
de apelación y absolvió definitivamente
abajo de cuatro cargos de crímenes
contra la humanidad entre ellos
asesinato persecución y violación
cometidos durante el conflicto la corte
penal internacional ordenó también que
se eliminarán todas las condiciones de
su liberación al igual que para el
coacusado salve un antiguo líder de la
juventud
la cia seguida de frutos
gracias a todos los que han creído en
nosotros en los próximos días tendré el
tiempo para hablar al pueblo de costa de
márfil de áfrica pero por el momento
solo tengo una cosa que decir que el
pueblo de costa de marfil se una
pero barbón no está totalmente fuera de
peligro podría ser encarcelado a su
regreso a costa de márfil ya que fue
condenado por rebeldía a una pena de 20
años después de presuntamente saquear
una sucursal del banco central de los
estados de áfrica occidental en su
momento
y seguimos con información política
porque el gobierno de níger aseguró
haber frustrado un intento de golpe de
estado en el palacio presidencial en la
capital del país vecinos de la zona
escucharon disparos durante la noche
mientras las fuerzas de seguridad
intentaban impedir que un grupo de
soldados tomara el control el golpe se
produce antes de la juramentación de
mohamed bazum quien a sus 61 años gana
unas elecciones presidenciales en
febrero será la primera transición
pacífica de poder en este país con una
larga historia de golpes de estado
en este distrito de la capital de
nigeria pueden respirar tranquilos sin
embargo en las primeras horas del
miércoles los vecinos afirmaron haber
escuchado disparos
se cree que el ruido de las balas
provenía del palacio presidencial armado
cuando el gobierno condena este acto
cobarde y regresivo que buscaba atentar
contra la democracia y el estado de
derecho con el que nuestro país está
firmemente comprometido cerré problema
anghaie luego darla el gobierno informa
a la población que la situación está
completamente bajo control varios
miembros del ejército han sido detenidos
en relación con el presunto intento de
golpe la aparente toma de poder se
produce días antes de la toma de
posesión del recién electo presidente
mohamed bazoum una victoria que ha sido
discutida por su rival mahaman usman el
ex presidente argumenta que ganó las
elecciones a principios de este año el
traspaso de poder del viernes es
histórico para el país del sahel será la
primera transición democrática en níger
desde que se independizó de francia en
1960 níger tiene una larga historia de
militares tomando el poder por la fuerza
el país ha sido víctima de cuatro golpes
de estado desde que se separó de sus
poderes coloniales
el gobierno interino suanes y el grupo
rebelde movimiento de liberación popular
de sudán del norte firmaron un documento
como paso previo para un acuerdo de paz
que garantice la libertad de culto y
separe la religión del estado
un paso crucial que hay en el camino
hacia la paz después de meses de
estancamiento en las negociaciones con
el gobierno de transición de sudán este
domingo los rebeldes del movimiento de
liberación popular de sudán del norte
firmaron una declaración de principios
previa al acuerdo de paz para poner fin
a los numerosos y prolongados conflictos
étnicos del país
creemos que esta firma de la declaración
de principios es un verdadero comienzo
para mostrar la determinación del
gobierno del periodo de transición y el
compromiso por un cambio real que lleve
a la justicia y la paz
para todos
la facción rebelde participó en las
negociaciones previas de 2020 con las
autoridades de transición que lideran el
país desde la destitución del dictador
omar al bashir en 2019 luego de semanas
de masivas manifestaciones pero fue uno
de los dos grupos que aún no había
aceptado el pacto bueno debemos alabar
este paso audaz del general durán que ha
llevado a la firma de esta declaración
que se considera un logro importante en
la negociación que puede conducir a una
paz sostenible y a una unión justa
las condiciones impuestas por la milicia
son la garantía de un estado laico sin
ningún papel de la religión en la
elaboración de leyes la disolución de
todas las milicias del ex líder
islamista al bashir y la modernización
de las fuerzas armadas del país de no
cumplirse sus demandas pedirán la
autodeterminación de las áreas bajo su
control desde hace dos años el gobierno
interino busca estabilizar sudan y
ayudar a que sufrague el camino hacia la
democracia prospere historiadores
franceses publicaron un informe
condenatorio que expone los fallos de
francia durante el genocidio en ruanda
en el que 800.000 personas la mayoría de
la etnia tutsi fueron masacradas en el
año de 1994 la principal conclusión de
este informe es que francia tiene una
responsabilidad abrumadora por sus
fallos militares y políticos pero el
informe no acusa a francia de
complicidad en el genocidio
27 años después del genocidio de ruanda
un grupo de historiadores franceses
publicó un informe afirmando que francia
tiene una responsabilidad abrumadora en
el genocidio las autoridades francesas
apoyaron al régimen que era racista
corrupto y violento se afirma en el
informe basándose en el argumento de que
los rebeldes tutsis eran una amenaza
para los hutus
el gobierno francés armó y entrenó a
estos últimos estados que los
consideraba sus aliados
las autoridades francesas instaron
políticas que estaban completamente
desconectadas de la realidad
y ese acercamiento empeoró la crisis el
sitio
week el informe denuncia la ceguera de
francia ante las preparaciones del
genocidio en 2019 france24 emitió el
testimonio del antiguo jefe de la
cooperación militar en ruanda dijo que
él había alertado a sus superiores sobre
el inminente riesgo de genocidio pero
francia no hizo nada entre varios puntos
del informe destaca el hecho de que
francia se negara a arrestar a los
líderes justo cuando entraron en una
zona segura creada para las víctimas
andante francés surgió a parís el
permiso para detenerlos pero el
presidente francés se negó tal y como
explicó el antiguo jefe de su oficina
las naciones unidos nos dieron un
mandato humanitario no uno judicial no
estábamos trabajando para una corte
cuando acusó a francia de complicidad en
el genocidio pero el informe de los
historiadores franceses dice que ningún
archivo corrobora esta teoría y para
finalizar tenemos música esta vez a
cargo de dos de las voces femeninas más
relevantes del continente africano
se trata de la nigeriana de mi alada y
la beninesa angélique kidjo quienes
subieron de nuevo para pedir dignidad
con su nuevo sencillo a duetos titulado
dignity estamos grandes de la música
africana protestan contra la brutalidad
policial y levantan su voz por las
víctimas mortales que dejaron las
manifestaciones contra el grupo especial
de la policía en nigeria que llevaron a
su disolución el vídeo que también viene
acompañado de un canto a la vida y a la
maternidad con esas imágenes finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días
ustedes pueden continuar con más
tempranas 24 punto com lo vemos más
adelante con más información
y ahora
pictet y tiene dos hijos
si quiere
esta te indican mansamente distrito no
sólo en la campus 1 porta médico médico
millones y pide por con en ti no te dice
no
[Música]
y